[Music]
Christian
h
[Music]
Christian
what in the world
[Music]
she needs a
mic she's ready to run the
[Music]
service hello welcome
everyone welcome to the table
good
afternoon good afternoon everyone
welcome to the
table
Yeah I want to welcome everybody to the
service today my name is johnine Horton
I'd like to welcome all of you online as
well I want everyone to know that you're
not only welcome here but you are
celebrated here I have a couple
announcements the state of the table
will be one week from today on September
the 29th think of it like a family
meeting only it's for the
church so what we'll do is all of the
details about leadership transitions
finance and much more and if you call
the table home then please plan to
attend next week 6:15 to 7:15 and now an
announcement from Maggie
thank you I almost forgot this was
happening I you looking at me I'm like
uhhuh um but I'm going to take my kids
ministry hat off for a minute and put on
my Elder Team hat um as the table
continues to grow we want to make sure
that we have an elder team who
represents our church body and right now
our Elder team is made up of myself and
Brett Marissa Martinez Gary uh Miner and
Don Jacobs and we would like to see that
team grow by a couple of more people um
to get a broader representation from the
table and we count on those who call the
table home and are committed here um as
members to be part of that process and
we always open up and request feedback
from you guys when we're trying to
discern that to see who have you felt
like is already operating that way in
our community who have been the people
that feel as though they do represent
table um values and um we trust your
input into that and um at this time we
just want to say if you have been here
for a long time and you feel like the
table's home but you haven't done any
kind of official like yes please Count
Me In I'm part of this community or I am
a member but you would like to be part
of speaking in that process please find
Brett or any of us elders and let us
know so that we can make sure you're
included in that and um just take that
next step because we will be sending out
information on that um I honestly I
think that'll be in the next couple of
weeks so we're just taking the end of
September kind of to um get the word out
and then we'll be sending out the
requests to those who call the table
home who are members here to speak into
that process so let us know if that's
something you want to be a part of thank
you thank you Maggie we appreciate your
service we appreciate everybody on our
Elder
Team all right in two weeks which is
October the 6th that would normally be
our hat Creek first Sunday meal but we
are replacing that this time with a
potluck so this is called family fav
faes potluck and you can sign up to
bring a dish by scanning the QR code
that's on the
screens all right also if you are not
registered to vote Allison where are you
there see the hand waving Alison will be
in the lobby after the service and she
would uh love to sign you up if you're
interested in that and we do encourage
you uh to do
that I wanted to bring your attention to
the candle that were lit at the
beginning of the service uh these
candles are a sign of the presence of
Christ Among Us they symbolize his full
Divinity and his full
Humanity now I'd like to do a call to
worship we will exit the kingdom of
noise and hurry and
productivity and we will enter the
kingdom of silence and still ESS and
simplicity we will cross the threshold
to Sacred
Space a place of prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ the
revelation of
God the heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart and
may we all come home
[Music]
you guys go ahead and stand with
us it's a day for singing so you guys
can join
in
see Rising with the rising of the
[Music]
sun
goodness rushing in and filling up my
[Music]
lungs your
faithfulness is here and now the
evidence is all
around I bless your name I give you
praise today is a day for
singing Awake My Soul come on and praise
the Lord today is a day for singing sing
on my
soul
oh my
praise
the oh my soul
oh my
soul today is a day for
singing yes
[Music]
a new
song He's welling up from deep inside of
me and there is New
Life Hallelujah I have been redeemed
I've been
redeemed I bless your name I give you
praise today
is a day for
singing sing awake awake my soul come on
and praise the Lord today is a day for
singing oh my soul
oh my
soul
praise the
Lord my soul
oh my soul
today is a day for singing today today
today is a day for
singing the valley to the mountain the
desert to the
Fountain oh I will praise you from the
morning from the morning to the evening
as long as I am breathing today is a day
for singing let's sing that out here we
go from the valley to the mountain the
desert to the
Fountain oh I will praise you yeah from
the morning to the evening as long as I
am Brea today is a day for singing oh
today
today is the day for singing sing it out
today today is the day for singing I
bless your name I bless your name I give
you praise today is the day for
singing Awake My Soul come on and praise
the Lord today is a day for singing
my soul from the valley to the
mountain to the
Fountain Lord oh my soul
Lord my
soul today is a day for singing sing
that again on my
soul my soul
the Lord my
soul my
soul today is a day for singing today
today today is a day for
singing last time today is a day for
singing
[Music]
all right kids y'all are dismissed to
your
classes your teachers are going to meet
you over there by those doors and then
they will take you down the halls I hope
youall have
fun thank you Katie and Maggie and
[Music]
Eve and
Risa we appreciate you guys so much and
to our Nursery crew who's already back
there taking care of our babies thank
you thank you
we are going to transition now into
prayers of the people so if you guys
would follow along on the screens and
say the parts in red aloud with us
together for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
Angelina for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and Hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
[Music]
amen Christ is my firm foundation
The Rock on which I stand when
everything around me is
shaking I've never been more glad that I
put my faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me down he's
faithful through
[Music]
generations so why would he fa
now he
won't no he won't no he
won't and I've still got joy in K
eyes I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be going
under I'm not held by My Own Strength
cuz I build my life on
Jesus and he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he fail
now he
won he w
oh he won't
fail he won't
fail he
[Music]
won't he
won't he won't
fail he won't fail
Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I scar when
everything around me is
shaking I never been more glad I put my
faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me down he's
faithful through
Generations so why would he fail
now he
won he
won he willon
F he won't
fa he won
he
W he won't
there he won't
fail he w
[Music]
rains came winds blew my house was built
on
you I'm safe with with you I'm going to
make it through say that again rain came
winds blue but my house was built on
you and I'm safe with you I'm going to
make it
through R came with BL
my house was built on
you life save with you I'm going to make
it
you I'm going to make it
through I'm standing strong on
through my house is built on you Christ
is my
[Music]
Foundation the rock of which I scare
everything about me
[Music]
Shen I've never been
more that I put my faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me
down he's faithful through
generation so why would he fail
now he
[Music]
won't he
won't he won't
[Music]
fail he won't fail
[Applause]
[Music]
he I wanted to read you guys something
that stood out to me this
week I was doing a study on silence and
this quote just kind of stopped me it
said silence is anything but passive
waiting it is proactive
[Music]
listening and for me one of the values
one of the benefits of continuing to
gather together as a church community
and engage this kind of time is because
it reminds me to slow down to
listen to quiet
myself and I'm sure you guys are like me
where our days are jam-packed from one
thing to the next thing and if it's not
a person in front of you then it's
social media and it's advertising and
it's all the things that are calling to
US soccer schedules and volleyball games
and parent teacher conferences or job
interviews or
bills or hard conversations
and in Romans 8 it
says in the same way the spirit helps us
in our
weakness we do not know what we ought to
pray for but the spirit himself
intercedes for us with groans that words
cannot
express and he who searches our hearts
knows the mind of the spirit because the
spirit intercedes for the Saints in
accordance with God God's
[Music]
will Jesus we've come together
tonight because we value Community
because we value spirituality and
disciplines that would connect us back
to your heart but we also gather tonight
to be
quiet to turn off our
mouths and turn on our
hearts to awaken our souls to your
spirit
to
listen to your
[Music]
voice so God even as we sing this next
song and we're saying words God I pray
that you would attune our hearts to you
and what you're doing here because we
need to remember where we've come
from we need to slow down and tune in to
the one who made us
to the one who has something valuable to
say and has been whispering it to us
from our
conception from the moment we were
created would we tune in and hear your
voice of Love Tonight
[Music]
all my world fall
short I got nothing
[Music]
new how could I
express all my
gratitude I could sing these songs
[Music]
as I often
do but every song must
stand and you never
do so I throw up my hands praise you
again and
again cuz all that I have is huj
[Music]
hallelu now know it's not much but I
have nothing else Fit For A
King except for heart singing
[Music]
hallelu huj
I've got one
response I've got just one
move with my arms stretched
wide I will worship
you so I throw up my hands and praise
you again and
again cuz all this I have is a
halelujah
and I know it's not much but I've
nothing else Fit For A
King except for a heart singing
hu Hallelujah
[Music]
come on my soul oh don't you get shy on
me lift up your song cuz you've got a
lion inside of those Longs get up and
praise the Lord
oh come on my soul oh don't you get
shout me lift up your song cuz you got a
lion inside of those Longs get up and
praise the
Lord oh come on my soul oh don't you get
child me lift up your soul cuz you got a
li inside of those BS get up and praise
the
Lord oh come on my soul oh don't you get
sh me lift up your soul cuz you got a
lion inside of
those get up and praise the Lord
[Applause]
PR the Lord
[Music]
so I throw up my hands praise you again
and
again cuz all that I have is
[Music]
aelu
hallelujah I know it's not much but I
have nothing else fit for
King except for heart singing
[Music]
hu
halelujah
God thank you for your voice that has
spoken love over us that meets us in our
challenging times and in our
celebrations that is
constant God would we tune into it would
we listen for your whisper would we make
space for your spirit in our
lives and we will continue to say
hallelujah praise
God thank
you thank you
for
[Music]
life for your
closeness for your
goodness in Jesus name
amen you guys can welcome the people
around you thank you so much for
worshiping with us
oh Grace and peace really good to uh
good to be with you all welcome you into
this space and uh yeah it's as always
that includes those join us online love
youall lots and uh yeah it's just really
really good to be with you so um the
title of my message this week is
ambition and our text we're kind of the
lectionary right now which is like the
the prescribed readings you know in the
church calendar so we I follow the uh
the UMC the United methodists kind of
their their uh lectionary so the the
reading this week is from James chapter
3 verses 13-
18 and uh that reads who is wise and
understanding among you let them show it
by their Good Life by Deeds Done in the
humility that comes from wisdom but if
you heart ber bitter envy and selfish
ambition in your hearts do not boast
about it or deny the truth such wisdom
so-called does not come down from heaven
but is Earthly unspiritual demonic for
where you have envy and selfish ambition
there you find disorder and every evil
practice but the wisdom that comes from
Heaven is first of all
pure then
peaceloving consider
submissive full of mercy and good fruit
impartial and
sincere peacemakers who seow in peace
reap a harvest of
righteousness so ambition it's a tricky
one you know is uh is ambition like good
I mean in the broader culture like I
definitely thought it was good you know
it's like a great no what else it's like
the only thing want for our kids like
yes be ambitious be successful be you
know like this is yeah uh is it good is
it bad is it like a little bit of
both is it like sometimes good but then
like sometimes bad depending on like the
context or exactly who's wielding the
ambition you
know uh I'm I'm going to go ahead and uh
with James here and say uh ambition I
think it's a bit like
amphetamines
energizing but addictive and
dangerous um this is the this is kind of
the trick with ambition now I should say
that may seem like a wild overstatement
you know sort of but actually I was uh I
did a quick little Google search this
week on ambition and amphetamines I was
just curious about like what would come
up and I was like oh of course it
brought up uh the rise of so-called
study drugs right how people are
basically using like Aderall and other
things they don't have ADD but they're
just using it it's like super popular
like universities among those that high
achieving crowd you know I bet half of
Harvard is on the ice SAR like it's just
it's the ambitious drug you know what I
mean like you don't want the downer the
chill it's like weed and you know I mean
that's the chill thing this is for the
like go go go go go go go you know I
mean it's uh so yes so I don't think
it's like some crazy stretch to say you
know ambition is like amphetamine it's
like I don't know it's sort of a uh
there's something to it and yet um and
here's the thing
like you know can ambition get stuff
done yes you know can when we're kind of
in that ambitious mode can we like move
some mountains oh absolutely will the
broader culture give us like two thumbs
up for sure uh and yet even in spite of
that James starts to he's kind of he's
poking you know starting to to dig
begins to kind of
unearth uh the the kind of uh maybe
rottenness that that sort of lays there
at the uh the the heart of ambition a
sort of um secret there there's a a
scene that's always stuck with me from
the film Gladiator and oh oldy but a
goodie
uh very violent but um but there's this
so you may remember the scene if you've
seen the movie so there's um this point
where the current emperor of Rome Marcus
aurelus is he knows you know he's not
long for this world so he's needing to
kind of choose like how how will his um
Empire kind of who will it be passed to
and and such and the trick is he um so
he tells his son uh
Commodus that uh he will not be the next
emperor of
Rome and
uh basically because he knows commus is
just not fit to rule not a good man it's
played a Commodus is played by walking a
very young walking Phoenix and it plays
that this is actually one of his kind of
first like I think maybe his first like
big film uh and I mean he plays it it's
creepy and you know it's all walking
Phoenix and uh so he tells him you know
you won't be the next Emperor uh of
Rome and commus the I I'll never forget
you can already kind of sens in Commodus
this sort of simmering murderous rage
you know kind of building within him uh
but what stuck out to me in the film is
his
reply because in a kind of an almost
sweepy voice he like looks at his father
and he says this is his reply he says
you uh you wrote to me once
listing the four Chief
virtues wisdom Justice
fortitude in
Temperance as I read the list I
knew I had none of
them but he
says I have other virtues father and
what's the first one he
names ambition
and just the way he says it in the film
you know
uhoh that is not good this virtue this
so-called virtue oh not good and sure
enough like in the very next scene he
basically like Embraces his father as
though to reconcile with him and just
keeps holding him real close to his
chest you know and sudden his dad's dead
like it's just right this is uh I think
it's kind of a a little moment of of
Revelation
uh you see there is this kind of dark
secret hiding in ambition it's something
I think we maybe don't think about and
but what is it I think it's as simple as
well ambition is just rather
selfish I when you think of even the
word ambition we don't tend to think of
like someone who's just sort of
magnanimous and just all about others
others success empowering other people
you know or even like the community the
tribe so ambitious for the for all of us
you know it's sort of like I don't know
that word doesn't quite apply to that
kind of person like usually when we're
thinking ambition who's it
about you know it's me like right this
is this is sort of the uh the heart of
of what's going on in
ambition and I think this is what uh
this is what James sort of sees in our
text very clearly which is why he just
comes out and kind of he names it uh
starting again in verse 14 says but if
you Harbor bitter envy and selfish
ambition in your hearts don't boast
about it or deny the truth such wisdom
does not come down from heaven but is
Earthly unspiritual demonic intense
language there but you can see like
James isn't pulling punches he's I guess
not
impressed with ambition to put it kind
of
mildly uh but he sees those two words
selfish ambition he sees the the kind of
Link AG between these two again verse 16
for where you have envy and selfish
ambition there you find disorder and
every evil practice uh in other words
it's sort of like um how does this
ambition kind of play out in the world
in our own life in a community I think
that's where James sees uh kind of how
how it plays out
and it's not so great Augustine in his
uh famous books confessions and then in
city of God uh speaks to this he names
uh worldly power ambition as actually
one of the primary obstacles to
following Christ he uh he says the
problem is that we have what he calls a
liido
principi uh which is Latin for a Lust
For Being first
[Laughter]
and uh I don't know about you but I can
relate to that during uh during covid we
we had someone we had a number of folks
it was you know quite a time for our
church and I think maybe I think in our
last count we lost maybe
30ish um adults and maybe another 10 or
15 kids through going through the co
season you know so was like a tough time
um but there was one uh a person in
particular that we had a kind of awkward
interaction around this so some of it
was um the reason they they left some of
it was like Drive they had already lived
ways away and then they're going to move
a little further um but also we weren't
open you know during covid and I think
they um were really looking they were
really wanting you know a place that
would be kind of more open or at least
opening sooner you know um so they were
just letting me know hey found a new you
know new Church community and and we'll
be going there and I was like okay well
I should say I in that moment
um I think well they probably
underestimated how secure I was that's
my guess I think they I don't know
probably they just underestimated so
they were just thinking you Bread's fine
you'll be fine you know and so what they
did they started to tell me just about
you know their new community and how
excited they were and it was an it was
amazing place a church plant similar to
ours started around the same
time um lots more people is kind of how
they phrase it like so many people so
energized like great energy when you're
there I mean just an incredible place
they're so excited to be there and I was
like this awesome I'm so happy for you
you know like um you know I mean I knew
what to say you know what I mean but
inwardly I was just kind of like dying a
little bit inside like just again I
think they thought I was more secure
than I actually was you know and uh so I
remember right after that I had this
like um fullon James chapter 3 13
through 18 kind of moment because they
had said you of course the name of the
church and so I go like I mean y'
immediately like this is like within 20
minutes of the conversation I'm like on
their
website and I'm like looking and sure
enough they're pretty cool you know I
was like yeah it's impressive that's
very impressive you know I mean like all
the things and the all the Ministries
and they're like already starting a
building campaign you know I mean like
all sorts of and uh I well this is again
this verse verse 14 but if you Harbor
bitter envy and selfish ambition in your
hearts that was me so the envious part
of course I'm there on the website and
I'm just like I just find that thing you
know you maybe have those moments of
just like kind of getting eaten up a
little bit with like oh my gosh there's
so and then it was like that just led
into this kind of
well we're gonna win you know what I
mean like I'm gonna work so hard make
sure I mean it was and now of course
it's like embarrassing to tell it's
ridiculous but in the moment I just had
this this kind of thing in fact this um
this sort of led me to one of my
personal rules now which is I just
generally avoid other Church websites
like the plague like if I have to go on
there for some reason I'll do it
generally because you would think like I
just do it no big deal there's other
people you know brother sisters siblings
in Christ noig you know but I just can't
I just get pulled into this lito
principi whole Vortex you know what I
mean and comparing like how many staff
do they have and you mean what's their
Building look like just just get like
pulled in Lord have mercy
you see this like this ambition this
this like lust to be
first it's lust to win oh I mean it can
be
energizing can get stuff done for
[Laughter]
sure but but what's kind of there at the
roots what's that
energy emanating from
James says uh like the devil you know
like it's not not good not the spirit of
Christ you know because just to be clear
I don't think the kind of what I'm
driving at here um is not the idea of
like oh yeah so be energyless you know
what I mean like just yeah who cares
let's just sit around later in the
message we'll get to some of what I
think is the kind of antidote to this um
but I think we've got to find a kind of
a new energy because what happens and
actually Augustin names this he says
this this uh libido principi it leads to
its twin brother which he calls it
libido dandi which is a lust to
dominate and he says oh this oh gosh you
know this is this is the way it's just
the way of the world you know this Lust
For Being first this lust to dominate it
can be this powerful
energetic kind of
thing uh and that can indeed Drive
cultures Drive individuals Drive
organizations Drive
churches kind of forward so to speak
into what looks like
progress that's the trick it's like a
it's sort of like progress without
progress it's like it's like fake
progress you know it's it it looks like
it but outwardly as Jesus says it's sort
of uh again when you get to the roots of
it it's like uh it's it's full of uh
dead men's
bones you know it's it's not a kind of
healthy it's not springing from a
healthy place it's it's kind of
springing up from this Lio principi and
dominandi and it's it's it's uh not good
um and again I I speak
as I speak gu someone
familiar with these these
uh challenges okay so what's the you
know what is kind of the proper response
I think um I'll just say ambition I
think it must be healed it must be
transformed into deep and loving service
of others I you know because again you
might wonder like when I honestly I
wondered this like I was scared have
been scared I'd say the last few years
um I've been kind of in probably a 10y
year process to sort of let go of this
but especially it's really at least for
me the invitation from Christ I think in
the last few years has really
crystallized more and more towards like
BR you got to like let this go you know
and
um my worry kind of was the thing I
hinted at earlier like well what will
motivate you know what I mean like what
what will be the energy what will be the
drive What will what will fuel the you
mean the desire to get out of bed in the
morning to do you know what I mean like
what if at least again if you're someone
who can kind of relate to this message I
know some of you this is not your
struggle you know so that's okay Lord
bless you you're sort of further down
the path you know than than myself and
others but if this is resonating with
you this might be a question you know
like well what then is going to replace
it what's going to be the the energizing
thing and I think this is what it is it
becomes a kind of uh uh not an evil
Spirit kind of energy but uh but it's
the Holy Spirit and what does it do it's
it's the spirit of God that kind of
launches us into this mode where we
don't want to just you know sit around
and do nothing but we we desire to serve
we desire to empower we want to bless we
want to bless we want to not even just
um Power we want to empower Empower
others lift up others right you can see
where the like the whole vibe kind of
Chang changes there's um a a good one of
the few business books I really like uh
Simon syic wrote this book um start with
why and um and he basically encourage he
says a lot of kind of organizations
people often start with what and how you
like what are we going to do how are we
going to do it we just kind of jump
ahead and he kind of says you know think
through
why why do you want to do that what kind
you know like what's the motivator here
and I I think that gets at the heart of
this whole topic because that's kind of
what you find at the roots right as
Augustine and James is kind of pointing
out oh a why when we're kind of in that
ambitious mode the why is sort of like H
you know what I mean it's sort of at
best a little sketchy and kind of shot
through with some selfishness hopefully
mixed though with some other motives you
know but at worst it's just not good
right and and so this suddenly becomes a
very different why that we're finding a
new new energy a new kind of passion
rising up from within us um I'll close
with this most of us I think are
familiar with um the famous you know
12ep uh program of Alcoholics Anonymous
and you might be um i' say the first
step is probably the more famous so the
first step is um honesty to admit we are
powerless over alcohol that our lives
have become unmanageable um but less
well known is the 12th
step the 12th step
is known as service which says having
had this spiritual awakening we now vow
to carry this message to others who are
struggling I think that's beautiful that
even in the 12 Steps it doesn't just
again Center on the self that would be
very easy to do to kind of like well
what else is this is about addiction and
my own struggle and so it's kind of
about me and that's okay you know like
and yet the 12th step is okay good you
found some healing you found some life
woo wonderful wonderful
now go you know go love serve
Empower right what is it it's that it's
that loving
service thing and and they kind of found
that actually my own
healing is bound up with the healing of
others that in essence it's not just me
grabbing the healing I can get you know
but actually two really fully mature
sure and be whole I've actually got to
kind of figure this out so to speak by
Grace like I've got to find a way um to
to allow Christ to send me out in a
heart posture of loving
service so this is uh this is the
antidote to ambition begin serving I
don't just mean here at the table or
something I'm thinking the whole world I
mean how beautiful even to see like work
you know this place where that's often
the ambition thing uh but to shift the
lens where it's not just about me and
whatever and my goals you know but it's
it's now like um it's about others and
isn't that kind of in a way kind of
skipping to the end like where people
often end up their life having
accomplish thing you know hit my goals
made this money did all the things and
then they're like it's so
empty why
like let's let's begin to figure it out
now because this is why this is the
transition we all have to make begin
serving without the need for Applause
without the need for Pats on the back
simply serve and find the Holy Spirit
find the energy the life the power of
God that empowers others growing within
you in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine we come to the one who loved us and
served us who washes our feet who
empowers us who died on the cross for us
rose again for us and and really all
creation so uh as you come forward I I
pray that that truth kind of sinks in uh
into you so the way we'll participate in
communion tonight is um we'll kind of
start here at the front row we'll just
work our way back we practice an open
table so if you're here tonight you want
to participate feel free to do it
remember the red is wine the white is
grape juice and then finally you can
partake however uh you'd like so this is
the
table not of the
church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so come you who have much faith
and you who have little you who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long you who have tried to
follow and you who have failed come come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
thank you guys for serving this
communion um we wanted to close out
tonight with a blessing um and just kind
of the reminder that instead of running
after you know
the ambitious path that we can also
Empower each other with grace truth and
wish for the things that matter over our
lives and those people around us in our
community so that's what we're going to
do as we close you guys can just receive
this song as Jesse sings it and sing
along if you would like in the
choruses wish upon you
peace a wish upon you
Grace A Wish For Love
of what you want and more of what you
need a wish upon you old life with a
heart that stays
young but most of all I wish upon you
love I wish upon you
Troth when all you feel is
down I hope you know that had an open
mind still knows when to shut things out
I wish upon you a brave heart that will
always rise
above but most of all I wish upon you
love as the sun set for the moon begins
to rise
even in the darkness you will find the
light you'll find the
[Applause]
light you find the
[Music]
light yes even in the darkness you'll
find the
light a wish upon you and need easy life
I wish upon you hard times I hope you
know them both Joy and Pain each need
the moment to sh wish you is that quick
to
listen use
that but most of all I wish upon you
love there the Sun
and the moon begins to
rise so even in the darkness you find
the
light you find the
yes even in the
darkness you will find the
[Music]
light well thank you all so much for
being here this evening we really
appreciate it if you are new we'd like
to invite you to scan the QR code or
pick up a visitor's card from the table
uh this is just so that we can follow up
with you answer any questions that you
might have and say thank you for
visiting with us
tonight um my name is Janine and if you
are in need of prayer or hug or just any
kind of General support it all I'll be
here after the service come find
me generosity is a key aspect of a life
of adoration and worship to give
financially you can find that
information at the QR code or you can
visit theable
tx.org
I wanted to remind you next week
is
the sorry the state of the table
and then two weeks from that will be our
potluck don't forget to go out and sign
up all right now let me send you forth
into your week with this blessing uh you
can stand you can hold your hands out
you can stay seated and open your heart
for these
words you are a child of
God yes you are a child of God this is
true true on your very best day and it
is true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
that you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed
we'll see you next Sunday and don't
forget to look for Allison if you want
to
[Music]
vote the sun sets oh the moon begins to
rise
so even in the darkness you find the
light you'll find the
[Applause]
[Music]
L even
in the
darkness you'll find the light
[Music]